[Music]
[Applause]
that doesn't always be bode well does it
my name is Steve moths and for 35 years
I was a senior inspector of air
accidents the air Accidents
Investigation Branch at Farnborough
you've asked me to view various clips
from movies and to critique how
realistic they are
the major accidents that I've dealt with
in those 35 years started with the fire
on the runway at Manchester in 1985 then
Lockerbie Pan Am 103 I've never heard of
electrical failures causing anything
like that normally electrical failures
if they happen are likely to lead to
gradual smoke they don't really result
in sort of explosions and fireballs and
things like this I've never heard of
that never heard of that because they're
protected they have circuit breakers and
fuses like you have in your car or a
home they would lose consciousness very
quickly within a few seconds pathologist
did say that it was likely if they're
free-falling out of the aircraft that
they would come to but they'd be so
confused and tumbling that they wouldn't
know what the hell's going on
firstly the aircraft wreckage looks very
realistic
I like that wiring looms are hanging
down like this is sort of thing you see
carpet seats everywhere dried pitting of
zombie are in different parts of the
aircraft depending on the nature of the
impact you can have a greater chance of
surviving but sometimes it's the rear
and sometimes it's the center over the
top of the wing because I on any
aircraft that is a very strong part of
structure but however if there's a fire
you're also sitting right over the fuel
tanks I wouldn't say there's necessarily
any great survival benefit being in and
I'll see if we've got an intact aircraft
and there's a fire develops then it's
nice to be on an RC rod and sort of
jammed up against the windows so I don't
think that's food statistics would bear
out their survivability is in an
accident in an impact is greater for oil
seats than through a window seat
I'll give it eight
[Applause]
what is going on I think it would simply
punch a hole in the window so you'd have
a bullet-sized hole what this thing
appears to show is the window
disintegrates completely and takes a bit
of the aircraft structure well again
that really wouldn't happen because
what's known as the window belt line so
the part of the fuselage that the
windows mounting is is extra strong for
that reason because the the holes cut
out for the windows are an obvious weak
point so they make sure that the
aircraft structure is is beefed up in
that area they can run down that's why
if you see every time the flight
attendants move a trolley and they stop
first thing they do is they put on the
brakes with their foot so it doesn't
slide I give it four
I don't think there's anything but
tinkling wrong I think that could happen
and that's likely the way that it would
if it if it did happen or if it does
happen the oxygen masks yes that's fair
enough they're designed to do that if
you have a depressurization that was
extremely rapid depressurization people
tend to think that it can happen with an
impact with a very heavy impact vertical
impact sometimes they drop down but
their primary purpose is to drop down if
the aircraft depressurizes an altitude
so all right so the visual effect it's
known in the trade as the rugged jungles
yeah goodnight
[Music]
yes well several things wrong with this
clip Bruce Willis seems to be able to
reach inside the structure of the
aircraft and pull a pipe out which
starts fuel gushing out I don't think
that would really be possible another
misconception amongst film makers is
that jet fuel is incredibly flammable
it's not it's the reverse it's much less
flammable than petrol first start I
don't think the flame going from his
cigarette lighter along a trail and then
up onto the aircraft would ever happen
certainly not only knows low
temperatures it's something about Bruce
Willis films I isn't there I'm getting
where he's caught up in a space shuttle
to try and add things bouncing off rocks
you know the most delicate thing in the
world you know if like a plane can bring
those down
feels really stiff sir he says the
elevator has gone stiff as though it's a
lift well no they're always referred to
in the plural elevators they're the
movable surfaces at the rear of the
aircraft that control by the pilots to
make the aircraft go up or go down or
pitch up and pitch down we need to dump
the fuel in an emergency you always dump
fuel no I'm afraid no that's the last
thing on your mind to be trying to get
the aircraft under control dumping fuel
isn't going to help you the reason that
long-haul aircraft might dump fuel is
when they've got lots of time to prepare
for an emergency landing
in an emergency like this where they're
struggling to control the aircraft
dumping fuel wouldn't even enter into
the heads
like rolling an airliner inverted and
flying it inverted I really don't think
so I'm not sure the structure would
actually would stand you break a wing or
something because they're not meant to
fly under negative G and now we got a
river and Emanuel important aside first
the the scenario of this is he's a
little bit obscure and he talks about
hydraulic failure and then talks about
going to manual he then as this big
handle that he pulls and select and it
gives him manual control most modern
aircraft it wouldn't be possible to fly
them in manual and bigger aircraft you
can't fly to manually they're too heavy
Reese seems to be relatively
straightforward what's known as a dead
stick landing in other words no engines
operating and it probably knows hi so
he'd make he'd make the landing like
that try and touch down so the cockpit
would be well clear to the ground so
it's only if they ran into something a
solid object you know building or
something like that the cockpit would be
compromised the scenario doesn't really
hang together so I'll give that a five
[Applause]
after Clips I've seen that I think it's
most realistic I think that is what
would happen it's quite well done the
graphics what happens next though I
think is perhaps not so realistic now if
we look at the wreckage term of we use
to use was disrupted
it's very badly broken up as he runs it
and he keeps coming across passages like
this this person on fire I don't think
anybody would have survived the impact I
noticed an engine is still winding down
yes maybe but I think the engine would
be pretty much battered and jammed by
the by the impact
I'll get the eight
when you certify an engine design a new
engine design actually fired
birds at it of a specified weight and
then speed and check that the engine
doesn't break out and then it's gonna
get damaged that's what they don't want
is for it to stop ignition start it sort
of gives you the impression that the
engines failed completely I don't think
they did I think they weren't delivering
enough power for him to remain airborne
and I think there would have been a lot
of IT guys very quiet very still I think
there would have been a lot of vibration
I mean it is realistic and then it
should be because I think it's probably
one of the most documented sequence of
events in recent years isn't it
one of the things that I didn't like
about this film
it wasn't the technical side of it it
was the totally invented antipathy from
the National Transportation Safety Board
and Sully himself in other words that
they come across as bullying and
accusative he didn't do the right thing
that was a complete invention I know I
believe Sullenberger himself said that
that was not that the NTSB actually
supported him he famously was a film
called castaway where there is an air
crash he I think he's the only survivor
that was quite a bit unrealistic you
know with engines continuing to run and
at one point he's in danger of being
sucked into this engine that was still
running even though it was in water it's
got to be at least nine
zero nine zero
[Music]
maybe there's documentary documentary
evidence that says that Howard Hughes
did fly in shirtsleeves without a seat
belt in what looks like a car seat with
a headrest in what appears to be quite a
nice sizable room I mean this is
supposed to be a fighter isn't it a
prototype fighter or fighter bomber
incredibly complex you see bits of the
structure there's pipes of wires
everywhere
I really would very much doubt if the
prototype of a new combat aircraft was
as roomy and uncluttered as that
now if we look at the the wing root here
that's visible we can see a dent in it
but in the other shots of it it's pretty
much intact apart from the bits it's
lost I'm not too sure about the landing
gear running across the roof six
I'm intrigued about what these devices
are that they're fastening into the
fuselage I think the first time you
tried to put any weight on this they
pull on it
those were pull out there's not a lot
hold you made the fuselage would just be
way assuming it's a real urban sequence
and not CGI it must have been
pre-prepared so yes you can you can do a
shot like this but the aircraft's
probably got strengthened ringing inside
it an invisible rigid ring would have
given it a fire but I'll give it one for
the fact that he's well prepared
[Music]
the sound of the engines is all wrong
they have recorded a print
piston-engined aircraft which makes that
through a growlings dive-bomber type
noise this aircraft is a turboprop which
makes a sort of more like a wine because
it's got propellants it makes they all
make the same sound and that's not the
case this was quite well known at the
time quite famous accident at the time
because people survived for thinking for
72 days in those freezing conditions and
on the Friday the year the macabre bit
was that they actually had to resort to
cannibalism to survive but covered
cannibalism those who died in the
accident
there's a wooly light flashing that says
pull up I'm pretty certain that that
would not have been fitted to this
aircraft at the period of 1972 was it
1973 it's a system called ground
proximity warning system and it was
developed and mandated in 1974
I think this they're getting it confused
with what is known as a storm warning
because the pilot is heaving back on the
stick to try and avoid the mountain he
would probably be in danger of stalling
the aircraft
[Music]
one of the first things to know is the
whole sequence is lasting far too long
if I timed it from first impact with the
mounting where the tail came off until
it came to rest and it was a minute
another very common movie misconception
because I guess they just want to
stretch out the action a bit you know
the real thing probably would have been
over in a few seconds and certainly this
massive ski jump that the aircraft
performs and in lands it's still
interact it's not even deformed it would
have been a massive crushing blow I'd
give it 6 out of 10
I've written here like this one a water
landing is is a ditching lot of media
get that wrong they talked about the
deer craft ditched on land ditching is
purposely executed landing on water it
depends on the type of aircraft the
Sully film showed that it can be done
with a modern airline it's one of the
very few cases of a modern airliner
actually successfully ditching it's not
the worst thing that can happen I happen
to know that the b-24 Liberator was a
difficult aircraft to ditch it had a
habit of breaking into to the poor old
pilots were the least likely I think to
to get help I don't think the Gunners
would stay in their turrets if they know
they're going to ditch they would take
up a position probably somewhere around
the middle of the aircraft I'm gonna
give it nice I've wrote here what is
going on